it's going to bring you these very
latest pictures of prime minister Rishi
sooner arriving in Hiroshima in Japan
he's popped the umbrella up it's a rainy
day there as he steps down uh the stairs
there on uh on uh in Hiroshima with his
wife he is of course arriving for the G7
Summit
um that starts on Friday the three-day
stomach in Earnest but there will of
course be meetings on the sideline lines
prime minister fumio kashida has already
had talks with the U.S President Joe
Biden who's also arrived there in
Hiroshima the G7 of course uh probably
top of the agenda is at Ukraine and
Russia's invasion of Ukraine Hiroshima
of course the site for the first atomic
bomb attack and Japan always Keen to
promote peace prime minister there being
greeted by a dignitary he's from Japan
as he arrives ahead of the G7 Summit we
will bring you any updates from that as
and when we get them